three weeks from today we will stage the
most important presidential election
since the Civil War three weeks until
that election and one candidate has
spent the last 48 hours insisting there
is already voter fraud happening at
polling places that do not yet exist
three weeks until that election which
that candidate says is rigged unless he
wins because of voter fraud which has
happened 31 times in the last 1 billion
votes cast in this country three weeks
until that election and the leaders of
one party are still chained of their own
volition to the captain of the Titanic
three weeks until that election and
their candidate has shown himself more
and more hour by hour day by day to be
manifestly unstable sexually criminal
deranged bigoted and despotic yet to
paraphrase Winston Churchill these
so-called leaders have been given the
choice between shame and loss of office
they have chosen shame they will get
loss of office later but it is not to
them I want to speak at this three-week
mark before the election it is to those
who will vote for Trump more importantly
it is to those who may vote for Trump to
those who bluntly can still hear me if
you're thinking of voting for Donald
Trump I'm sorry this country on your
life in it are not what you thought they
would be nor what you thought was
promised to you I'm sorry that you think
you have been denied something by
Americans who don't look like you or
pray like you I would remind you that
when your grandfather or
great-grandfather or whoever came here
and whenever they came here they were
blamed identically because they were
Catholic or Italian or Irish or just
foreign I do not doubt you have
grievances nor that our system of
government has been so overcome by the
political industry that you see no
chance that you will get what you really
want I have felt that way too nearly
every day of my adult life but I'm not
here to agree or disagree with your
grievances I am here to urge you to
recognize that what you see as your
solution will in fact end with your
slavery because you know this man you
have always known this man voting for
Donald Trump is like not getting the car
you want
you instead take the car you have and
you drive it into the wall while you
were in it while your family is in it
while your country is in it this
election is not a question of policy or
political correctness or rebellion
against the Machine this is sanity
versus insanity and freedom versus a
police state this man is crazy we have
indications that he is violent against
women
he has been violent since he was a child
he hates and disparages people based on
how they look or where their parents are
from and anyone and anything who goes
against him is not treated the way you
would treat them or it he does not move
on he does not work harder he does not
find another way he says it's all fixed
it's a plot it's a lie it's the fault of
the Mexicans it means war he has
uncontrollable anger and you want to
give him nuclear weapons you know this
man you have always known this man he is
the lying used car salesman across town
he is the contractor who puts a hole in
your wall then vanishes he is the
fast-talking huckster on the late-night
TV commercial he is the husband or the
wife or the girlfriend or the boyfriend
who promised you forever and ran off
with your heart and your money in your
life you may not like Hillary Clinton or
her policies or anything about her but
if she is elected you will have four
years to find a presidential candidate
of your own whose true goal is not to
rob you blind and four years from now
you will still have a presidential
election and a vote and a country Trump
will give nothing to you but shame and
regret and shackles he will take and he
will keep whatever he can get his hands
on it is the story of his life he boasts
about doing that he says giving
employees a paycheck is the equivalent
of your neighbor sacrificing his son in
the war you really think he will give
you anything you really think he will
give you a better job more money from
women to business this man is grabbed
first and ask questions later and you
know that and in the rubble the rubble
of your life and a political science
fiction nightmare version of a fascist
America made real this will be on your
conscience it will be your fault
not Trump's he is merely the con man who
is fattening you up for the kill he ends
his appearances with the Rolling Stones
song you can't always get what you want
he is telling you in advance how much
more warning does he have to give you
you know this man you have always known
this man there's been a lot of time
wasted on trying to understand the
nature of the strategy Donald Trump has
used since his profile as a potential
serial sexual criminal began to emerge
two Fridays ago well there is no
strategy this is the point this is not
strategy this is him he has been acting
in this campaign especially in the last
two weeks as if he has already been
elected already is the president and
that the rest of us are just annoying
him by asking him about these harrowing
tapes and these harrowing accusations he
behaves as if we are being rude to him
by not simply agreeing with him and
praising his countless amazing skills
and wonderful accomplishments and his
vast piles of money as if on your
deathbed or after it the question you
will ask or that will be asked of you is
how much money did you make Donald Trump
is defending himself by claiming that
his victims were too unattractive to
attack not as some kind of political
strategy not as some kind of clever
answer he is doing this because that is
who he is and that is what he expects to
be able to do as president the
presidency would be the same as his
current life 70 years of hedonism and
selfishness and abuse except backed up
by the power of the presidency and the
military he has been the dictator in his
life and now he intends to become the
dictator in your life you know this man
you have always known this man you have
seen him and you have seen him recently
he is Bill Cosby
he is OJ Simpson he is Bernie Madoff in
nearly every individual thing
úp says to you he is lying distorting
rationalizing contorting blaming self
murdering but in one sense he's the most
truthful candidate we have ever had the
awful dishonest egomaniacal dangerous
hateful candidate that he shows the
world every day that's really him he is
not putting on an act he is not hiding
anything more than the details he is
everyday showing you his soul the
monster you see is the monster you will
get only this monster will now have the
power to issue executive orders and to
pull that funny guy Jose you know works
at the restaurant or on the farm out of
his house and throw them into a
detention camp and if you protest you'll
have the power to throw you in the
detention camp alongside Jose elect him
and you'll spend the rest of your lives
trying to undo your vote you already
know this man promised you honor the
outcome of this election if he loses and
then said he was backing out of that
promise you have already heard him spend
hours explaining that if he loses it
will not be because he and you have been
rejected it will be because he and you
have been defrauded what makes you think
he believes in the things about this
country that you love that you have
believed in and depended on and taken
for granted since you were a kid what
makes you think he would not say in his
inaugural address the people have spoken
so there's no need for any more
elections why on earth would you think
that having gotten you to give him your
vote to give him your money to give him
your freedom that he would ever again
bother to ask you what you want why
would he listen to you why would he do
anything for you who would make him do
anything for you if you want to vote for
him because nobody pushes him around
what are you gonna do when he does
something you don't like what makes you
think that if you dare to raise a
complaint that he would not treat you as
he has treated those who during the
campaign have opposed him or criticized
him or merely pointed out what he has
said you may cheer now when the
reporters at his rallies are booed and
threatened you high-five when somebody
sucker punches a protestor how do you
think President Trump will treat you if
you feel like he's broken his promise to
you how do you think President Trump
will treat you if you do not
jump when he says jump how do you think
President Trump will treat you if you do
not applaud when he says applaud he has
already shown you how you know this man
you have always known this man you know
that this is the kind of man which
oppressed people around the world have
spent their lives trying to escape from
and have lost their lives
staging revolutions against elect him
and you are signing the death warrant to
your own freedoms but even if you think
he's going to lose but you must vote for
him anyway in protest you will have
still opened Pandora's Box in this
country because this might be the most
skilled and dangerous con man ever to
rise up to try to cheat us out of the
democracy you and I both cherish but he
might not be the next one might be far
worse and far more skilled and whichever
is the case he certainly will not be the
last of the con men and when the first
one finally soft sells enough of your
friends to gain that sacred office of
the presidency you as much as I will be
at his mercy
if Trump merely does well while losing
this election it will be open season for
demagogues and fascists and white
supremacists to try to take over this
country your country you have already
seen it diagrammed for you Donald Trump
has shown you his math he has gotten
this far gotten within three weeks of
the presidency based on summoning hate
and fear and directing it towards a
group Mexicans Muslims Jews liberals
reporters doesn't matter which group and
nothing guarantees that the next time it
won't be your group you know this man
you have always known this man and among
all the things you know about this man I
know all that has gone on since Trump
started it in June of last year one
statement he made should jump out and
grab you by the throat and it should ask
you very softly but very firmly why
would you ever ever consider turning
over this country to this man why would
you ever ever consider encouraging his
type
just by giving him your vote when the
woman on the plane 35 years ago Jesse
leads accused him of groping her he
tried to defend himself not by getting a
believable witness not by proving he was
not on that flight not by the way you
would defend yourself against such a
charge if it were not true and your
whole life was at risk because somebody
had slandered you no Trump said you
should know he didn't do it because
quote believe me she would not be my
first choice that I can tell you she
would not be my first choice so ask
yourself one question before you vote
for this man who would be his first
choice your daughter
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space